[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir d'être
au musée lambiné le musée lambiné se
trouve à Versailles c'est le musée
municipal d'art et d'histoire de la
ville de versa
alors aujourd'hui j'ai aussi le grand
plaisir de rencontrer le commissaire
d'une exposition qui va tout juste
démarrer je suis en présence de Monsieur
Ronald poly qui est belge qui vient
d'enverse qui est historien et auteur
notamment son premier livre s'appelait
les lanciers rouges s'appelle toujours
d'ailleurs et vous êtes un spécialiste
des portraits militaires vous êtes le
commissaire de l'exposition ou mais mais
de qui de de du peintre un peintre que
vous avez retrouvé qui s'appelle
Alexandre Jean Du Bois draonet ces dates
sont
1700 90 bravo
1800 34 34 il est mort jeune le pauvre
alors déjà pourquoi est-il tombé dans
l'oubli et comment comment ça se fait
parce qu'il eu quand même son heure de
gloire à l'époque ou pas ou pas à mon
avis quand on voit son parcours h h
c'est quand même extraordinaire c'estd
c'est extraordinaire parce que il était
il avait accès dans les maisons de la
duchesse de Berry les orléons le roi
d'Angleterre le roi des Pays-Bas donc
toutes les cours d'Europe il avait ses
accès là et à mon avis c'est commencé
dès le moment qu'il est passé en
Angleterre il est passé en Angleterre
pour faire une série de de de disons une
centaine de petits portraits militaires
pour le roi Guillaume I euh et à ce
moment il a presque plus fait des
portraits de civil de civil ou même des
militairees parce que les militaires
c'était son clientèle à la fin il a mis
tous ses œufs dans le même panier et il
était un peu oublié en plus en
1831 il y a Charles Chabé si je me
trompe pas qui qui écrit son
dictionnaire euh sur les peintres
français du 19e hm hm et là on voit les
premières erreurs ah oui c'est même
pendant la vie du bois de Ronis qu'on
qu' qu'on voit les les erreurs la date
de naissance faux fausse
euh il y a confusion entre son beau-père
qui était pierre draonet et le peintre
voisraon ensuite il y a une troisième
entrée dans dans le dictionnaire c'est
Alexandre Jean du boois donc on a
Alexandre Jean dubis Alexandre Jean
Dubois draonis et on a pierre draonet
ouais ça fait des confusions ça fait
confusion en plus ils attribuent des
œuvres de pierre draonet à du bois mais
aussi à du bois
dronis d'accord bon c'était vraiment mal
parti hein voilà en plus il est tombé
dans l'obli mais aussi et ça c'est
marrant c'est sa veuf est passée de
après son décès à l'avant du tout est
passé à Paris hm hm
et personne parle de du bois de Ronis ça
alors à son décès elle a acheté une
concession au cimetière
Saint-Louis mais après si je me trompe
pas après 13 ou 14 années elle a vendu
la concession de s Marie donc il était
fait pour être oublié oublié ouais il y
avait un sort alors justement ce
Alexandre Jean du boraonis il est je
l'ai pas dit il a des attaches avec
Versailles parce qu'il est venu vivre à
Versailles il il s'est marié donc avec
la femme dont vous parliez qui était la
fille d'un peintre décorateur donc Jean
Jean draonet et il a accollé le nom de
son épouse à son nom à lui voilà bah
après ça ça fait des confusions he il a
cherché mais pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
fait ça parce que Pierre draet il avait
une entreprise une entreprise de de de
de peintre décorateurs disons il
travaillait pour château d'accord
et c'est après le de son beau-père il a
repris donc Alexandre J a repris
l'entreprise pas de son vivant et
probablement pour ça il a d'accord et il
avait un atelier à Versailles c'est ça
probablement oui mais on sait pas où
probablement mais on sait pas il y avait
pas un quartier des artistes à
Versailles je crois pas on croit pas
d'accord la maison où il habitait là il
y avait une sorte d'atelier parce que la
maison est construit en deux bâtiments
donc on a bâtiment A et là annexe B hm
hm B était plutôt pour l'entreprise ok
mais quand on lit euh la construction de
du du global de du de la maison euh on a
l'impression qu'il y avait quand même un
atelier il était dans quel quartier
euh c'était rue rue mon repas maintenant
c'est c'est c'est rue Général Galieni ah
oui d'accord je vois bon bref alors cet
artiste oui vous l'avez donc mis en
scène il y a à peu près 70 toiles on est
d'accord oui on ouais oui et il y en a
deux qui sont ici en permanence qui
appartiennent au musée lambiné alors
quelles sont-elles ces deux toiles voà
c'est deux portraits de la famille Huard
qui étaiit des marchands de drap à Paris
il y a un troisième portrait d'un nuar
qui se trouve au Louvre d'accord donc on
a madame har et son fils qui sont ici
euh euh à l'ambin l'autre don on n pas
pu monter le montrer l'autre
euh si l'ouvre ça devait être restauré
tout ça ok donc les autres toiles vous
les avez obtenu par des prês par comment
ça s'est passé des prês en fait j'ai
commencé à chercher il y
a un peu plus que 3 ans j'ai j'ai j'ai
vraiment me jeté sur sur le sujet euh je
connaissais on parle pas de la série qui
qui se trouve en Angleterre parce que ça
fait partie de la collection royale on a
là une
95 petits portraits dont on a quelques
exemplaires ce sont des copies cette
fameuse série qu' l' un peu coupé du
monde voilà
voilà à côté de ça je connaissais
environ une une vingtaine de tableaux
d'accord mais vous vous les avez
découvert comment ces tableaux
en faisant des
recherches par votre votre intérêt pour
le tout est commencé avec le premier
livre ce sont les lancier rouge parce
que il était dans le régiment de Lancier
rouge il s'est engagé volontaire voilà
il était ici à Versailles ouais et en
fait c'est le début je dis pas vraiment
le début de sa carrière parce qu'il
pignait déjà avant qu'il est entré dans
l'armée voilà on peut pas dire s'il n'a
pas été dans le régiment qu'est-ce qui
était sont son devenu son parcours il
était déjà peintre professionnel on peut
dire enfin gagné sa vie oui on peut dire
peintre de salon il était en 1812 il
était déjà au salon voilà il il a fait
tous les salons ouais voilà euh presque
presque pendant sa vie il a fait les
salons de de de de de de de Paris euh
Gan Bruxelles Academy Royal Academy euh
ou il était vraiment fois à Londres donc
oui donc là où il pouvait exposer dans
dans les salons il était
donc ici à Versailles il a vraiment
commencé à peindre les généraux et les
officiers supérieurs les officiers de
son régiment mais c'était son travail à
l'armée ou faisait ça en
plus ça c'est un détail très
curieux parce que il faut recommencer il
faut retourner en 1812 allons-y en
1812 il avait déjà ESS échappé à deux
conscriptions ah oui en payant en payant
ou avoir la chance dans la loterie
d'accord parce qu'à la fin la
conscription c'était une loterie h 1813
qu'est-ce qu'on voit Napoléon a été
battu en Russie il y avait plus d'armée
h hein le le maréchal Bertier le le
premier livre de la première lettre de
1813 qu'il envoyait à l'empereur c'était
en disant sire il n'y a plus d'Ar mais
bon comme lettre de nouvelom ouis il y a
mieux il y a mieux donc à ce
moment c'était très difficile à échapper
la conscription les remplaçants étaient
très chers ah oui donc il avait du on
doit parler de Dubai à ce moment-là
Dubai avec avait le choix de où attendre
la conscription h ou s'engager comme
volontaire d'accord comme volontaire
c'était mieux parce qu'on pouvait
choisir l'unité d'accord donc il a
choisi la Garde Impériale comme vLite
vLite c'est quoi vLite c'est une sorte
de jeune qui entre dans
l'armée la famille paye une sorte de de
de pension pour pour payer l'uniforme et
ils reçoivent des des des leçon c'est
une sorte d'école militaire dans le
régiment formation formation voilà
euh donc c'est pour ça qu'il choisit la
Garde Impériale parce que jusqu'à ce
moment-là la garde impérial c'était un
peu la garantie pour survivre les les B
parce la G c'était toujours sont
toujours tenu en réserve d'accord 1813
bon plus parce que il y av plus le choix
mais bon pour lui la GTE impériale
c'était le plus sa le plus sa donc il
entre il vient ici à vers
au moment que les officiers du régiment
reviennent de Russie ceux qui reviennent
et il y a là le colonel major du bois
colonel aussi un du bois mais Auen auun
lien entre les deux et ce qui est
marrant
c'est après 2 3 mois on voit que le
colonel major commande un portrait en
pied de lui un portrait en pied de sa
femme et de ses enfants ce sont des
portrait on a le portrait du
voilà
et ce qui est marrant c'est il y a une
une une une sorte de de de connexion
entre les deux ils sont devenus des amis
h HM parce que la façon comment il est
reproduit sur le
tableau ça dit beaucoup parce que il y a
d'autres portraits de de de de de de de
dignitaire ou je sais pas hm hm avec le
peintre à côté deux ça existe c'est pas
une pièce unique mais en
général la de la deuxième personne ne
regarde pas vers le public c'est le la
personnage la plus importante qui
regarde faire le public d'accord ici h
on a un de bois de bois qui qui tous les
deux regarde vers le
public si moi je commande un portrait
c'est le c'est mon portrait c'est pas la
portrait de de de de l'autre donc ça
c'est un peu spécial c'est spécial que
après très peu de temps le peintre était
tellement dans une bonne relation avec
le colonel major avec le sujet qu'il
pouvait faire ça donc le regarder droit
dans les yeux regarder le public comme
peintre à savoir le voilà voilà et ça
donne une une une une une une une
impression d' d'une d'une confiance en
lui-même c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
important après c'est le colonel major
qui retourne en 1816 il retourne au
Pays-Bas parce que les lanciers rouges
étaient au début d'origine
hollandais donc le colonel MAJ à ce
moment-là il est devenu général il
retourne au Pays-Bas et c'est lui qui va
demander à de boisé de venir au Pays-Bas
pour pour faire des portraits de sa
famille HM de tous les nobles des
ministres de et comme ça voà il arrive
lancé tranquille chez le le le le le
prince Guillaume euh d'orange je
comprends qui est là non c'est pas lui
ce sont ses enfants oui B c'est presque
pareil bon d'accord comment on peut
définir ce ce style de Dubois dronais
c'est que c'est du réalistme vous dites
porcelainisé comment c'est réaliste et
c'est certainement réaliste il y a des
des des des portraits comme
euh qui d'ailleurs Louise d'tois donc la
fille de la duchesse de Berry c'est un
peu c'est un peu por comment on dit
porcelinisé c'est pas moi qui l' inventé
hein penisé
et mais c'est c'est un c'est un peintre
de son temps de son époque ouais est-ce
qu'il est est-ce qu'il avait le droit de
d'être vraiment réaliste ou fallait
toujours un petit peu embellir les gens
à mon à mon avis il était peut-être pas
pour la duchesse de Berry parce que là
il y a la duchesse de Berry ouais il y a
des gens qui disent que c'est un peu
amélioré ah bon ouais ouais qu'est-ce
que ça devait être je sais pas je sais
pas je l'ai pas connu
euh quand même il y a les deux portraits
des souverains de Naple hm hm qui sont
comme ils étaient c'est vrai c'est
décrit dans les mémoires de castalan si
je me trompe pas et lui décrit la reine
et la roi et c'est vraiment c'est 100 %
comme comme il sonent sur le tableau il
était quand même assez incroyable ce ce
ce peintre parce que il descend d'une
famille de d'ébénistes on dit merci ça
veut dire ébéniste c'est ce que vous
m'avez dit donc c'était des des artisans
d'art il a été baigné quand même dans
une culture artistique il est il est
venu comment à la peinture en quelques
mots parce que là on est on est bientôt
à la fin ça je sais pas il y a toujours
des question qu'on a pas ok il faut il
faut il faut savoir que il y a 3 ans
avant Dr an si on passe 3 ans on savait
presque rienexistait pas quasiment pas
il n'avait rien on avait une fausse date
de naissance on savait
que disons ses parents connaissaient ses
parents le régiment donc tout de petits
détails on connaissait mais on savait
rien concernant en fait sa vie ses
connexions
et parce qu'il est un membre de cette
famille C
vraiment de de de grands ébonistes ouais
à mon avis les du bois les du bois euh à
mon avis ça a l'aider avec ce contact
d'accord mais oui puisque vous dites sa
famille travaillait déjà pour les pour
les cours voilà européenne ils ont lancé
vous m'avez dit c'est pour moi qui je
sais c'est vous ils ont lancé le style
wi1 c'est Jacques dubis qui a
lancé un de ses un de ses ancêtres qui a
lancé le le style le we8ekend oui donc
c'était déjà une famille très importante
c'est une FAM et à mon avis c'est là où
il avait déjà eu une une éducation déjà
artistique entre guillemets esthétique
il était esthétique certainement mais il
il a à mon avis il a aussi
eu comment le savoir vivre pour faire
des des des contacts avec les gens il
avit ce qu'il fallait pour les relations
publiques voilà voilà bah sauf qu'après
tout s'est cassé c'est c'est est-ce que
c'est normal parce que son public
c'était des familles royales
18 1830 la duchesse de Berry il était un
des des peintres favoris de la duchesse
de Berry et c'est
émig en Angleterre
1830 donc soudain c'est une sorte de
clientèle qui qui qui qui qui je
comprends de l'autre côté
1831 il reçoit une commande du roi
d'Angleterre Guillon hm hm qui l' connu
à dieep probablement pendant les
vacances que que la duchesse de les
vacances les séjours que la duchesse de
Perry avait chaque année à dieep parce
qu'on a un dessin du du du du à ce
moment-là encore duc de Clarence qui est
devenu Guillaume
hmm dessiné par du bois draonis c'est
daté 8 octobre 1800
89 non
euh donc là on voit déjà qu'il a été en
contact avec le futur BO d'accord est-ce
que à cause de ça qu'il est qu'il a reçu
la commande pour faire une grande série
de petits portraits en Angleterre on
sait pas donc ce sont tous ces petits
détails qui qui qui manque encore
d'accord ok et donc le lien avec Jéricho
vous m'en avez parlé tout à tout à
l'heure'estce le li avecérit c'est c'est
c'est c'est très
curieux il faut il faut savoir que
Jérico était souvent à Versailles parce
que ça alors j'étais pas au courant mais
enfin peux pas tout savoir
Monsieur donc Jéricho avait son oncle et
sa tante qui qui qui habitait à au ches
au chet ah ben voilà a quelques
kilomètres d'ici ch c'est pas Versailles
he c'est pas versaill mais tout près je
présente
donc donc Jéricho passait beaucoup de
temps aux écuries de la gardne impériale
à Versailles pour faire des études des
chevaux mais aussi des militaires ah et
au Louvre ils ont un dessin
je
papier et il y a là un portrait d'un
lancier rouge hm hm en pied hm hm dans
un un format
euh pas beaucoup utilisé par jé
inhabituel inhabituel voilà ça c'est le
mot donc inhabituel pour ces croquis
d'accord c'est aussi un autre style
parce que le visage est un peu plus
euh détaillé travaillé travaillé
euh ça aussi est différent que tous les
autres des
d'accord quand on voit ce dessin hm hm
et on voit
l'autoportrait de notre amie qu'on a ici
euh à l'exposition de Jean Alexandre de
Alexandre Jean Alexandre Jean pardon du
bois de Ronis c'est lui c'est pas vrai
c'est lui j'ai ça alors j'ai demandé à
plusieurs conservateurs et expert
d'art pensez-vous est-ce que c'est le
même et la majorité a dit il y a pas de
de de doute c'est le même alors c'est un
clin d'œil ou c'est ça se faisait
d'aller prendre la tête d'un autre mais
non c'est c'était deux deux peintes et
peut-être ils se sont rencontrés dans
dans les écuries oui mais pourquoi il a
mis oui c'est ça ah oui donc c'était
vraiment lui ah mais oui c'est pas un
autre à qui il aurait mis la tête d'un
autre je suis un peu tu
hein ah mais non bon bref il l'a peint
il a été peint par jécoo voilà il y a un
dessin un dessin une esquise en pied
incroyable du
ensuite en
1820 il paye un portrait d'une femme hm
hm dédicacé à mon bon ami
Théodor bon il y a d'autres Théodor à
par à versaill mais pas beaucoup parce
que j'ai vérifié
euh si on prend le portrait qu'on a daté
de 1820 hm hm et on le compare avec un
autre portrait
présumé être la tente de Jéricho mais la
fameuse du get voilà avec laquelle il a
eu une affaire et
enfant ce tableau est daté autour de
h quand on les compare et de nouveau
j'ai demander à d'autres gens qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez c'est les
mêmes
on présume que c'est la même parce que
c'est c'est c'est dangereux jéich avec
Jéricho c'est toujours dangereux de
comprends en tout cas c'est passionnant
cette histoire cette enquête que vous
avez mené et alors ben il a une vie très
très riche et bon il avait un talent
incroyable et il est mort très jeune il
est mort très jeune à peine 40 ans en
rentrant de Londres il est on sait pas
de quoi on sait pas de quoi encore un
mystère ouais il est retourné de Londres
il est passé parce qu'ils avaient un
appartement à Paris hm hm euh rue La
Bruyère il a passé là
et sa femme l'a emmené à versaill parce
que le climat été un peu
la voilàur donc est décédé ici euh
d'accord et au bout de 13 ans sa
concession plus rien oublié d'accord ben
écoutez sur ce Ronal P un grand merci
c'est absolument passionnant je pense
qu'on a un peu dépassé le temps mais
c'est pas grave et bah ça donne très
envie de découvrir cette magnifique
exposition dont vous êtes le commissaire
et j'espère à très bientôt merci pour
tout au revoir à tous merci de nous
avoir
[Musique]
suivi